Hello Internet.
Thoughts compete for space in your brain:
cat photos, news stories, beliefs structures,
funny GIFs, educational videos, not-so-educational
videos and your thinking inventory is limited.
A thought without a brain to think it, dies.
Now we can treat thoughts as though they're
alive.
Specifically alive like germs.
That might sound weird but stick with me.
Take jokes.
Jokes are thought germs that live in your
brain -- and when you tell the joke to another
brain, you help it reproduce.
Just like when you have the flu and sneeze
to help it reproduce.
This germ gets into its host by snot through
the mouth and this one by words through the
ear but it's reproduction either way.
Logging on to your social media then, is exposing
yourself to everyone's mental sneezes.
Each post a glob of snot with an thought germ
trying to get in your brain -- if not for
permanent residence then at least long enough
to get you to press the share button and sneeze
it with everyone you know.
In this analogy then, a funny cat photo with
a perfect caption is a super-flu.
Now just as germs exploit weak points in your
immune system, so do thought germs exploit
weak points in your brain.
A.K.A. emotions.
Once inside, thought germs that press emotional
buttons get their hosts to spread them more
-- measurably more.
Well, except sadness, sad thought germs don't
get very far.
Awe is pretty good which is why websites that
construct thought germs like biological weapons
arm them with them titles like "7 whatevers
that will blow your mind" or "The Shocking
Secret behind... this thing"
But anger is the ultimate edge for a thought
germ.
Anger, bypasses your mental immune system,
and compels you to share it.
Being aware of your brain's weak spots is
necessary for good mental hygiene -- like
knowing how to wash your hands.
Because even without intentional construction,
any thought germ on the Internet can, on its
own, grow more infections as it spreads.
To talk about why, lets forget anger for a
moment and go back to that cat photo.
Every photo ever taken is a thought germ,
and most die a quick death like the bazillion
cat photos (or baby photos) posted on The
Internet that are never shared.
But a mildly funny cat photo can grow into
so much more, because just as transatlantic
flights were the best thing to happen to germ
germs, so the Internet is the best thing to
happen to thought germs.
For once on-board, that cat photo is a thought
germ that can leap into other brains.
And those brains might share it, and here's
the key point, occasionally, change it -- a
Photoshop here, a tweaked caption there.
Most changes are terrible, but some make the
thought germ even funnier, getting brains
to share it more.
Which results in more changes and a shot at
super-stardom.
A thus a lowly cat photo can achieve global
brain domination.
At least for a few hours.
The Internet, with its unparalleled ability
to share and randomly change thought germs
can't help but help make them stronger.
With jokes, that's awesome -- but with angry
germs not always so awesome.
No.
Angry germs, the more they're shared undergo
the same process, changing and distorting
to be more aggravating.
These have a better chance of spreading than
their more accurate but more boring rivals.
But like plagues, thought germs can burn though
a population too quickly.
Just watch your favorite meme generating machine
for a week and you'll see the life-cycle fly
by.
However some thought germs have found a way
around burnout.
Now, I must warn you, depending on which thought
germs live in your head and which you fight
for, the next section might sound *horrifying*.
So please keep in mind, we're going to talk
about what makes some thought germs, particularly
angry ones, successful and not how good or
bad they are.
OK?
Deep breath: calm.
Though germs can burn out because once everyone
agrees, it's hard to keep talking and thus
thinking about them.
But if there's an opposing thought germ, an
argument, then the thinking never stops.
Disagrement doesn't have to be angry, but
again, angry helps.
The more visible an argument gets the more
bystanders it draws in which makes it more
visible is why every group from the most innocuous
internet forum to The National Conversation
can turn into a double rage storm across the
sky in no time.
Wait, these though germs aren't competing,
they're co-operating.
Working together they reach more brains and
hold their thoughts longer than they could
alone.
Thought germs on opposite sides of an argument
can be symbiotic.
One tool symbiotic anger germs in particular
can employ is your-with-us-or-against-us.
Whatever thought germ just leaped to the front
of your brain, push it back.
This video isn't about that.
We're just talking about the tool, and this
one makes it hard, for neutral brains to resist
and its diviciveness also grows its symbiotic
partner.
This explains why, in some arguments gaining
more allies also gains more enemies.
Because though the participants think they're
involved in a firey battle to the death from
the anger germs perspective one side is a
field of flowers and the other a flock of
butterflies.
*Of course* planting more flowers will get
you more butterflies and getting more butterflies
will pollinate more flowers.
If there is some argument that splits the
population and lasts forever that even the
most neutral people find difficult to avoid,
you just might be looking at a super successful
pair of symbiotic anger germs that have reached
ecological stability
Now, one final depressing though.
Uhhhh…
I mean one more Awe inspiring point, that
will reveal the secrets of, ahhh -- actually
no it's just depressing.
When opposing groups get big they don't really
argue with each other, they *mostly* argue
with themselves about how angry the *other*
group makes them.
We can actually graph fights on the Internet
to see this in action.
Each becomes its own quasi isolated internet,
sharing thoughts about the other.
You see where this is going, right?
Each group becomes a breeding ground for thought
germs *about* the other -- and as before the
most enraging -- but not necessarily the most
accurate -- spread fastest.
A group almost can't help but construct a
totem of the other so enraging they talk about
it all the time -- which, now that you know
how though germs grow, is exactly what make
the totem always perfectly maddening.
Now, all this isn't to say that there's no
point in arguing.
(That's a different video).
Or that the Internet isn't amazing, or that
there aren't things worth trying to change
peoples' minds about.
And thought germs of all kinds come and go.
But it's useful to be aware of how thought
can use our emotions to spread and how the
more rapidly a thought is able to spread the
more chances it has to become *even better*
at spreading through random changes made to
it.
Sometimes that's great, sometimes it's terrible.
But if you want to maintain a healthy brain
it pays to be cautious of thoughts that have
passed through a lot of other brains and that
poke you where you are weakest.
It's your brain -- be hygienic with it.
So, of course this video is a thought germ,
one constructed very intentionally over time
to spread a thought germ about thought germs
-- exposing their secrets -- one could say.
But I tried as hard as possible, not to have,
this video attack your brain through emotions,
so it could use a little help spreading.
Please be a good germ vector and click the
share buttons to sneeze this at your friends.
Your coworkers.
Your family.
Infect them all.
You shared the video, right?
Well if you're still here, you really got
infected hard.
Only thing left is to click onscreen and sign
up to the email list which will get you exposed
to many more thought germs in stick figure
video form.